you
hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at a game that was played at the 1938
AVR OH tournament this was the strongest
chess tournament ever held at the time
on the white end we had an electrical
engineer and already a very well
established chess player Mikhail
Botvinnik he was one of the few to have
earned distinction in another field
while also playing at an elite level a
world-class level he would a decade
later become the 6th World Chess
Champion his opponent the current world
chess champion fourth world chess
champion Alexander L yakin the game
we're about to observe is very quick to
enter a technical phase right in the
middle game and on into the endgame this
game is a lot about finding ways to
improve your position while at the same
time finding ways to negate what it is
your opponent would like to do so let's
dive into this one and see how it plays
out we have ad pawn battle to be a bit
more exact we're working with a semi
tarush tension between C and D pawns
it's resolved somewhat on this move v
you have the option is black on how to
recapture with a piece or a pond it's
just a matter of taste taking with the
pawn you could end up with an isolated
pawn position okay
Knight takes d5 in this game similarly
White has an option with the e pawn in
this case a bit more reserved solid
securing the d4 point and paving the way
for Bishop deployment continuing knight
c6 Bishop to c4 not just to any square
oftentimes I'll talk about having an
opponent's piece in your camp and
challenging that piece well currently
black doesn't have any piece on white
side of the board but the one that's
closest to White's side is the knight on
d5
why puts pressure on this point and also
know that should there be a capture in
the square white is changing the
structure so that can tip in White's
favor at some stage a potential
structural change continuing we have a
capture black wants to deploy the bishop
but if Bishop to e7 white could then
take in the bishop has to take another
step to capture so the tension is
resolved on this move seven in the
center white recapturing with upon so
iqp position continuing Bishop e7 like
and Castle y can also capture on d5 but
doesn't like castles I'm not saying that
this would be a good decision I just
want to know this is the first time
where you could you could if you wanted
to make a capture on d5 but why is white
maybe not doing this black castles but
yet again there could be a capture on d5
but no rook to e1 half open file
guaranteed productive move and now after
b6 only now do we have a capture why why
only at this time is there capture on d5
well timing right what is white waiting
for whites waiting for black to exhaust
one tempo one move to deploy the bishop
to b7 because what else is it going to
do if you're considering Bishop to d7 ah
that's one of those half developing
moves black wants to try and develop
that Bishop fully along the main
diagonal only after b6 does white say
you know what I'm okay with opening up
this store I just wanted you to wait I
just wanted you to exhaust a tempo with
the b6 sneaky little detail but
important detail
continuing white strikes where black is
now weak Knight is vulnerable as a
result of b6
to defend Bishop d7 there's b7 there's
d7 but black should be welcome to a
light square Bishop exchange at this
moment we can judge good and bad bishops
by the central structure the light
square bishop for black is the bad guy
black would be welcome to this
going to be seven dozen nothing more
than defend the night once the Night
Moves it'd be staring at its own pond it
would be a different scenario if this
night was here then we could say the
bishop on b7 is a productive piece in an
indirect way because it supports a
strongly placed knight on e4 okay in
this game it's Bishop d7 white continues
to develop with a punch in this case and
now we have the under developing seems
awkward it is one of the suggestions
though by the engines under developing
offering a light square bishop exchange
you could also play rook to c8 here what
would maybe keep a player away from
playing Rick to c8 is you know at some
stage a7 could be a bit sensitive it's
lacking the defense at some stage you
know maybe take out the knight and then
take on a7 to watch out maybe your queen
gets trapped but yeah in this game it's
night to be a bishop F for keeping this
tension let black capture you and invite
you forward that's what we have now
Queen takes b5 a6 first pop quiz where
to go with the Queen feel free to pause
the video okay in the game it is Queen a
four I like this move primary function
is not to put pressure on a six that's
secondary this is the main focal point
c6 preventing what it is black would
like to do deploy the night so from here
we have Bishop to d6 if black played b5
guess where the Queen would go open file
where she observes c6 ok in the game
Bishop d6 there go the there go the dark
bishops and from here rook a to c1 e
team moves in it's clear white is the
one who stands better it's just a
question of how much light controls the
only to open files has a knight that is
far better and ok the King positions
they just offset neither side has a weak
King neither side has a flight square ok
how to continue we have rook a 7
looking for a rook to c7 or rook to e7
exchanging of what is you know just a
dummy piece a passive rook for an active
rook from here we have Queen to c2 this
is one of those positions where you have
to ask yourself what matters most you
know would this have been a moment if
you were playing to invest a flight
square for example there's still ways to
improve the pieces Queen to c2 is
important white wants to ensure that the
sea pile is under his control
for the duration of the game and because
of a move like this this earlier moved
19 we're going to see a lasting
advantage in the form of an active
versus a passive rook okay rook e7 in a
game one exchange on board one rook
remaining Queen c7 you can't support the
Queen because of the back rank issue
Queen takes rook takes rook c8 mate soon
enough
Queens are now gone white is still the
better side material is balanced but
this is a positional situation both
white pieces stand better where does the
knight even go doesn't even have a move
okay normally I give pop quizzes for the
side that's in the driver's seat I'm
going to throw one you know from blacks
perspective what do you do in such a
situation here this next move for black
is very important what move would you
play as black feel free to pause the
video okay the best move here a very
important move f6 it's a small move just
you know moving upon one step but it's
very important to make that move it's
very important to challenge this
strongly placed rook on the seventh rank
this
vizor square for the rook and there's an
additional benefit this is the primary
function to have f7 available for the
rook secondary negate the night it's
nice to assign two good reasons behind a
move f6 has those reasons connected with
it black is prepared to go to have seven
and if the hrickos to c8 the rook is
going to drop back of course the knight
would be hanging so the rook is ready to
challenge the black rook is ready to
change
ready to challenge the white rook on the
seventh and eighth ranks and at this
point black would be you know black
would love to get away with this one
with the draw you know white is
definitely the better side yeah let's go
for repetition okay this is the main
point behind f6 King to f1 it's the
endgame get the King rolling from here
rook f7 and now what would you do is
white here let me throw I know was this
the third pop quiz is there a limit that
I how many pop quizzes I could throw you
away okay I'm gonna throw another one
your way what would you do here is white
feel free to pause the video okay here
we go
rook c8 you know when I first reviewed
this game it was several years ago and I
think I took things away from this game
that I really didn't realize at the time
and this may have been one of them these
little technical points in the game you
know one thing that I could say is that
I know it would be a poor decision to
exchange rooks why would you exchange an
active for a passive rook rook that's on
an open file for one that's on a closed
file okay but to go to c8 first force
the rook back and only then avoid the
rook exchange this difference matters it
matters whether or not the rook is on f8
or f7 when white retreats the rook and
it's not just to any square the rook is
retreating - it's going to c3 where it
has some lateral options - maybe
pinpoint the queenside pawns now the
difference here is that if white drops
back to c3 before inserting a check on
that c8 square black could play rook to
b7 and this rook does a wonderful job of
paving the way for the King to now enter
the endgame this would now start to
become a bit of an equal ish position
the black king is actually pretty fast
to arrive at the e6 or d6 square I think
d6 would be one of the better squares
for the King to go to on a closed file
not going to get hit with checks by the
rook at least and yeah it just covers a
lot of squares a lot of entry points by
the white rook whether it's on the C
file or the e-file d6 would be a really
nice square to get to having said this
you know looking at this move rook c8
forcing the rook to f8 and only then
dropping back how is this different well
if the King tries to get active now the
rook gets right back there 7th rank with
check the King basically has to go back
here to defend the pawn stepping forward
you're going to get hit with a check too
scary to go in that direction I think
it's just flat-out losing and this rook
is just off the charts strong now okay
the knight could drop into h4 you have
to stop the knife from getting here that
could be pretty annoying and if you do
move like this you're really extending
the scope of the rook and this night
could be really quick to track down the
pond it's imperative that white insert
this check at this moment or right here
on c8 before retreating to c3 okay
no I just went off on a bit of a tangent
but I believe it is an important one
okay
from here we have g5 what would you do
is white here okay
91 the night is not doing anything from
f3 it's an out of play piece it's killed
by the f6 pawn it's time to reposition
find a new home that new home is d3 ok
h5 follows and now a very nice move
coming up feel free to try and figure it
out on your own here we go
h4 this is a pawn sacrifice this is a
this is a fight for a particular square
white wants one really good square for
the knight if there's one square you
could get that night - where would it be
f4 white is fighting for the f4 square
white wants this pawn to flinch on g5
move forward capture me if you want I
don't care I don't care about a material
loss my Jeep on is good my Jeep on will
control these two all the other pawns
are balanced same files they negate one
another and this Knight would sweep
right into f4 when he gets there
what is the knight not doing ok
black understands this and says I'm not
budging there's no way I'm giving you
that f4 square Knight d7 so it's off the
back rank but it's still one dummy of a
piece this pawn is laughing at it and
these other other two pawns are just
getting in its way
rook c7 rook f7
f 3 I really like this move this isn't
one of those yeah if you haven't already
figured out this isn't one of those
flash games
wow what a tactic no this is slow
methodical play probing for weaknesses
forcing weaknesses in your opponent's
camp but white it's clear really wants
that Jeep on to move or capture and is
willing to waste some time in order to
do so G for now hits it's becoming
unbearable black cannot maintain the g5
point so for example if ruck to g7 to
defend like consider a capture on the
square and now this rook is actually
overloaded white could take on g5 and if
rook takes Knight rook takes knight
White has just won a pawn and has still
a super active rook how sad it is for
the king he wants to contribute but
cannot okay cannot be maintained black
pushes the knight returns to e1 we know
where it wants to go and white knows
where the knight wants to go and so too
does black f5
d 3 & 4 just in the nick of time
can't get to F 4 that stopped now this
pawn is getting a little bit too
invasive white does not want to see this
pawn to step up that would be a great
inconvenience to the white king so f3
it's as far as your gonna go and an
additional thing I like about this move
is that it fixes this pawn on f4 these
two pawns I have all there's multiple
fixed pawns but look look at this dream
square an f4 if he ever gets there he's
just targeting additional pawns it's
ready to go into pac-man node1 pawn
dropping right off the other piece is
falling so because of this tension now
on f4 we have a three point piece
restricting a five point piece this is
creating an imbalance elsewhere in the
position kind of have you know in a way
I kind of see this position as a rook
versus Knight white rook versus black
knight position because of this pressure
here it's not fun to have this job okay
capture on f3 recapture a4 excuse me a5
is met with a for black is finally
getting active with the King some white
a little bit as well and it's kind of
tricky to do something for black you
know the night I was pointing out f4 but
also what about b6 there's there's a
responsibility by both black pieces okay
rook f5 in the game b3 it's tough to say
y b3 here okay it's defending a 4 but
it's also now going to an unprotected
square maybe there's some train of
thought that says well should this rook
it activates on stage and the beep on is
captured it's not going to hit with
check okay
can
we have King to d8 King EE to Knight to
b8 and I believe this moment here this
is going to be the last pop quiz feel
free to pause the video what does white
do next okay simple enough right you
could take upon but we don't have that
that is not the best move in the game it
is rook to g6 it's very important that
you not take this pawn for what feels
like the whole game
this Queen night or you know blacks
night here has been a struggling piece
but black is pretty close to having that
night not only activate and get to c6
but if it gets to c6 it will be getting
to d4 when it's on d4 it's gonna hit
hard it's gonna hit with check it's
important white not allow the night to
get to c6 so easily if you capture the
pawn in this position black would play
King c7 with an attack and when the rook
moves knight c6 is there and you're not
stopping Knight takes d4 with check how
easily things can turn if you don't do a
little bit of calculation and anticipate
the activity of this dummy piece it you
know consume not be so dumb okay rook g6
how is this different well you're not
allowing King c7 with an attack and
knight c6 to follow rook g6 king c7 what
do you do about knight c6 now nope can't
have that the knight is there just in
the nick of time to stop the Knights
activity prophylactic move
okay night a six a sad move to make it's
difficult road ahead for team black and
from here I think we basically just see
a lot of the pawns now dropping one by
one material has been balanced right on
up into this move 41 but here we go
they're gonna start to all fall knight
c6 threatening a fork and that knights
going to be hitting a lot of stuff right
the rook moves now Knight hits with
check the first pawn is picked up and
everything is getting hit at this point
rook d6 white simply defends keeps
pressure here and by maintaining the
night the knight is once more doing a
good job of controlling the black knight
Knight before in the game Knights are
now exchanged rook and pawn endgame
light is not only up the pawn but has a
better King position and just a better
rook everything is still better white
now up to pawns black wants to get into
this Square
sure cut off the king put pressure on
the white pawns cut off the King if you
take on this square
there's many approaches here rook to f5
is one the look at this it's kind of a
weird position for the black rook
there's no good move to the side or
forward and when it goes backward to one
of these three we just have the rook and
he's just gonna vacuum up the two fourth
rank pawns and it's just too much of a
material plus for white so in the game
we have rook c6 looking at the c3 square
and really the last thing to know
getting the rook here will have
everything defended rook takes b4 will
defend this base point and there's no
fear of the black rook ever getting this
pawn in creating a passed pawn the king
is nearby
to defend f3 so just a few more moves in
this one what is this now three pawn
advantage just play it out of a little
bit more like it's one of the pawns back
the threat here is to save the pun with
h5 rook takes King to d3 and at this
point black resigns it's had enough
everything is still tipping in White's
favour material-wise piecewise just
completely ground down King here and you
know the rook is always tied down to
defending if it did play out a little
bit more I don't know rook h4 King here
rook e1 check just scooping up another
pawn this is three pawns too many okay
well this is as far as it went in this
one after King to d3 once more team
black resigns
so that's all I have for you in this one
I feel that this is one of the more
instructive games really going from that
middle game into the end game nice
little test I believe you know if you
happen to be an instructor viewing this
video
- maybe challenge your students with
plenty of technical points to really be
taking away from this game anyhow as
usual feel free to leave any feedback to
this video in the comment section below
hope you're having a great day
and I hope you maybe took a thing or two
away from this one that's all for now
take care bye
you